out loud enacted Atlanta's fascinating
City it's a cultural economic powerhouse
but it's got a nasty underbelly
on any given night in the state of
Georgia 300 kids will be sold for sex
and Atlanta has been identified as one
of the hospitals for sex trafficking
I don't regularly cry behind the camera
and that's something I've only ever done
once
Atlantis Airport is the busiest airport
in the world that kind of becomes a bit
of a guys for sex traffickers to operate
in
there's thousands of people passing in
and out of the airport it's easy for
them to maneuver breeze in breeze ow no
one's any wiser I came across Donna when
I was researching the airport she runs
an organization that helps train people
who work in the industry how to spot the
signs of potential sex trafficking
victims she had such a profound effect
on me she's really strong
elegant woman strong and then you frame
up and get the lights up and get all the
technical things out of the way and then
start rolling and then she just spoke
about her story and where she had come
from I was traded for guns
I was traded for weapons I was traded
for drugs
I was traded when it just to discipline
me sometimes to punish me I was beaten
and left for dead three times I have
never been so moved actually in an
interview it all just played out on her
face the awful trauma of what she'd
endured at the last point of my life
when I realized I was not gonna be able
to get away from them
I wanted to live and I wanted my
children to live and I wanted a better
life so my way out was to go to prison
Jen and her and myself being three women
who were clearly struck by her story and
getting emotional in front of her as she
told it she you know we were on her side
I have been arrested 27 times I went to
jail seven times and that last time I
knew that I was going to have to go to
prison or they were never gonna leave me
alone I made sure that my children were
safe and when we were arrested I did not
allow them to bail me out there was a
point where she went back into her story
and I started to cry I couldn't stop it
all of sudden everything looked out of
focus and I'm trying to be professional
and you know wipe the tear from my I
just it it got me how dare you okay
you're on your own unique yeah I saw
back there crying I'm like I seem to
have that effect on people
but and I hope to god I never have to
use it is that how dangerous these
streets are mm-hmm yeah but it's best
for you to be armed yeah because you're
not really
[Music]
they used to work as a stripper and
dancer and she was on the margins of the
sex industry she decided to give back
and dedicate herself to rescuing people
on the streets women in particular she
does that by driving around and handing
gift baskets out the window with her
phone number and a card inside that was
she's pregnant she's a date to drive how
often will she be forced to have sex
probably say five or six times at least
a day per day minimum
you know the pimp will make sure look
you need to go make this you know high
first and then make her late look you
gotta go self you gotta go make me some
money because it's almost like they have
to be drugged up to do what they do
hey sweetie can I give you a gift basket
you could see it Casey trying to make
those connections when she's working so
I was sat next to her in the car
and every time the window went down if
she got a girl to come over she'd
immediately say something flattering
about the girls appearance what's your
name
Queen I'm Casey nice to meet you so I
love your hat and she's coming from a
hard place she's not judgmental of these
women understand that you know it can
happen to anyone she was young these
women died they disappear they get hurt
and people don't know who they are or
where they are and Casey is actually a
kind of human filing cabinet for these
women if there's a missing woman with a
tattoo of a figure of 8 on the side of
her neck they'll go to Casey because
Casey would have spotted it how do you
keep doing it why won't you not like
once she like it's like everything I've
been through in life the abuse being
molested running away
quitting school using drugs and to see
where I am today and just see that that
could have been me you know I mean like
why not
I was really pleased that we got to
speak to the FBI it's really hard to get
the FBI on camera they don't like
journalists coming into headquarters
because they don't like compromising the
identity of agents it's money money is
look is the motivator here these pimps
are in traffickers look to exploit
children and adults primarily for the
financial benefit involved in it
the average age of entry for children
that have entered this lifestyle is as
for as approximately fourteen years of
age or their vulnerable children and
these traffickers feed off of that
vulnerability much like any predator
does
[Music]
I'm philosophically opposed to strip
clubs I just hate the thought that women
are selling their bodies and being
objectified just generally fuels a sense
that women are to be bought and sold and
their bodies are not their own so didn't
really want to go but Casey said it's
going to be a good idea you've got to go
the people who are running a strip club
are good people and they're doing
interesting things what is the scale the
problem you know are we talking about
you worry about a couple of girls here
and there or is it something that you're
always paying attention to the pimps
will use any place you know they are in
our everyday society moving around women
are being trafficked children are being
trafficked
first trick I returned I was 15 years
old I also run away from from home
parents wrong drugs she was one of these
throwaway children that's the term they
use first was paid for sex at the age of
15 by somebody who round the grocery
near her house and I eventually ran into
an actual pimp and that was when I was
about 17 years old she's making a
mockery at you if you got a bother you
and she ain't get no money you make it a
joke at the fish Scooby yeah traffic to
run her from state to state marketed her
for sex with men who knew she was young
at the time did you have any sense that
you were a child and he was sexually
exploiting you the commercial game at
the time no when I look back on it now I
think you know I was I was 17
I was up I was a baby you have to be a
strong person to live that lifestyle
everybody thinks oh it's easy you're
just laying on your back you know it's
just sex and but it's not just sex it's
you're opening your soul to every Joe
and you sleep with I don't often say
this but listening to Elena's story as a
woman was really upsetting actually
because she became vulnerable because
she was a woman a child actually at the
time and there's a certain connection
that two women talking together half was
it hard to leave
he was very hard why because you've been
with somebody that you've put your all
into somebody that has
taught you how to survive make a living
I mean I made more money than most
lawyers doctors so it's like how do you
turn on somebody that has taught you so
much and has put food in your mouth
showed you a hustle and do you did
develop feelings for them and it's just
as awful tension because she clearly
knew that the only reason skooby cared
about her was that she was making money
for him and it was an abusive
relationship in the extreme and she
couldn't help herself
like she'd been so neglected that a man
who sold her for sex and hurt her was
better than nothing would you now
consider yourself free of that life No
I fight it everyday when I fight it
every day